on georgia but there's that you can get
loads of free resources um maths
teachers all over the world upload stuff
this is called geogebra tube and i just
did a search for trigonometry and pulled
out some here's one um
what this does is it shows you the
graphical interpretation of all the six
trig functions so you should be familiar
anyone who's not familiar with why the
unit circle produces the y-coordinate
being sine the x-coordinate being cos
and we we've got primary teachers here
as well who may not be familiar let me
just quickly show you
on a unit circle
that's the unit circle and this is
obviously how
most of us introduce trigonometry
beyond 90 degrees
you take a
triangle within the first quadrant
so the first quadrant here second third
and fourth
and
this is a unit circle so the hypotenuse
has value one this is the x coordinate
of this point x y this is the y
coordinate so that length there um so we
have
this angle measured anti-clockwise from
the positive axis theta
so looking at that triangle we've got
sine theta is opposite over
hypotenuse which is y over one so y is
equal to sine theta
and cos theta is adjacent over
hypotenuse which is x over one
so therefore
x equals cos theta so what it means of
course is this point here the
x coordinate at any point is cos of this
angle and the y
the y coordinate is sine of that angle
and of course the gradient
is y over x
and so the gradient m equals y over x
which is rise over run which is
um sine theta
over cos theta but it's also opposite
over adjacent so it's equal to tan theta
and also just while i'm standing with my
legs apart um
sine squared theta sorry i'm pointing
the wrong thing cos squared theta
plus sine squared theta equals one is
just pythagoras's theorem um you can
move this red point here and you can see
how cyan and cos the blue and the red
change and the tan is a really good one
because um
this tan theta here if you just think of
that as you know p
um then
tan of this angle is p over this
distance which is one
that distance is is tan theta and i'm
not going to go into why but it's quite
easy then to see why
um
these three represent
cotsec and
cosec okay but it's pretty cool you can
go all the way around and see how they
vary
that's quite nice and another one which
is quite nice
oops
is
this one
and it's gone back oh no
it's there oh no that's the same one
that one
i'm losing time here um okay so that's
very similar
to the one that we saw before it shows
you how
the the y-coordinate maps out as you
move around and i get students to
explain why is it
that in that first bit why doesn't it
just go diagonally like a straight line
and you know they they prove to me which
basically means they explain
that in this first bit here
it goes up very very quickly as as the
angle
increases so
over here
it goes up really really quickly in that
first little bit so that by the time you
get to 30 degrees you've already gone
halfway up and then it slows down
because of the arc of the circle so
that's really quite conceptual early
uh what else have i got
okay
that one there
i think this has got to be my all-time
favorite i can't stand all stations to
central
i can't stand it um it's the epitome
of not understanding
what you're doing
um and that's not to say
sorry i'm just doing this because that
lady over there can't see me
it's probably a relief for her but
anyway
so look this is great because watch what
happens
um
as i move that you can see the two
places where on the unit circle where
sine
of the angle is in this case 0.62 or
minus
0.3
and you can see it working
and that's just such a
beautiful dynamic graphic and then
you can do it for sorry i meant to do
for cosine um and you can see
as you change it what happens and you
know it's pretty obvious that cosine is
going to be positive
in this quadrant here and in this
quadrant here because you can see cosine
is the x coordinate and cosine's going
to be negative here you don't need all
stations to central you do the same with
10 being the gradient is obviously
positive here and here sorry that's
supposed to be a straight line here and
it's negative here because the slope is
negative
cool
um right
oh you'll love this
so this is a sine wave
it's going through all the
the range of human hearing
and of course sand is a longitudinal
wave so it's caused by the
particles in the air the molecules being
vibrated in this direction
whereas electromagnetic radiation is a
transverse
oscillation
i'm going to cut to a little bit nearer
at the end
just because i want to get through very
slightly
and sometimes still hear it still hear
it put your hand down when you stop
hearing it
yeah i could have just phrased that
question like put your hand down if
you're old and keep it up
so
i had i had a competition
we had to sing a sideways
um we had to sing a song
who could sing the best sound wave we
had a competition okay i'm gonna try and
demonstrate
okay i did that deliberately um
this is audacity this is audacity most
language teachers know about it it's a
free resource most schools have it
already installed okay that wasn't a
great attempt initially hopefully it got
better
it's not one of my best but
uh and then
okay it sort of vaguely resembles the
sound wave at this point uh it's it's
the purest of sound um the sine wave and
then as you go further along
oh look at that that's pretty i think
around it
and then look and look what happens when
you get more and more harsh you get all
these overtones cropping up i mean that
was actually just clipping because i was
too loud but look it's the same
frequency
same
time period but
you can compare and you can measure it
with a board ruler same time period but
more frequency so you get a more
complicated waveform and that's really
interesting it you know you can start
talking about fourier series and things
um
and in fact we talked a little bit about
music and about the fact that
it's the shark again
the fact that the musical intervals are
actually all precise ratios so i i i
didn't play that audacity clip back but
i could have played it back at 1.5 to
speed you can do all that within
audacity and it would um sound if you
did it as 1.5 and sound a fifth above so
i can't remember what i'm saying
or something
oh sorry yeah that's about fifth um
and these are the what i want to call
the just scales but what interestingly
in music all of the 12 um
you know semitones have an exact ratio
which are displayed here
but
in different keys
that means that you'd have to tune an
instrument to the key you were playing
in and
when when they used to play
originally they did tune instruments for
every key and when they came up with the
idea of a piano and
equal tempered scale came about and
these are the approximations to the
ratio using equal temperament and then
bach
bach came up with this
wonderful
thing called the well-tempered clever
clavier that's the
front of it
it's in german so i won't read down in
german um and i'm going to read out
something from wikipedia here which is
obviously the font of all knowledge the
the just scale sometimes referred to as
harmonic tuning or hem hole scale
because naturally as a result of the
overtone series simple systems such as
vibrating strings or air columns you
could actually get a member of the class
to bring in a stringed instrument and
actually play harmonics on it to
demonstrate um the equal tempered scales
develop for keyboard instruments such as
the piano so they could be played
equally well or badly in any key it's a
compromised tuning scheme
equal tempered system uses constant
frequency multiple between the notes of
a chromatic scale hence playing in any
key sounds equally good good or bad
depending on your point of view and how
good your hearing is and with your you
have perfect pitch
1722 js bach uh produced a well tempered
clavich clavier which was a composition
of preludes and fugues in all 24 keys
major and minor
so
that's just a little bit more
information
i think i'm going to just move on from
there